Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbands für die deutsche Wissenschaft.
Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle zur 97. Ausgabe dieser Gesprächsreihe.
Und heute, ja, heute reden wir mal wieder ein bisschen über Bildung.
Da gibt es ja, wie alle wahrscheinlich meiner Meinung sein werden, eine Menge Bedarf
und auch eine Menge Nachholbedarf.
Und insbesondere dann, wenn es um Digitalisierungsfragen geht und das im Besonderen in Deutschland.
Und deswegen sprechen wir heute mal genau darüber, wie man da was dran drehen kann
und dazu begrüßt ich meine Gesprächspartnerin, nämlich Julia, Julia Freudenberg, hallo schönen guten Tag.
Ich grüße dich, freue mich hier zu sein.
Ja, herzlich willkommen bei Forschergeist.
Du bist, das nehme ich mal vorweg, die Leiterin der Hackerschule in Hamburg, kann man so sagen oder?
Ja, das bin ich und das mache ich sozusagen 40 Stunden am Tag und sehr begeistert.
Mhm /bejahend/ und das machst du auch schon eine ganze Weile?
Ja, ich habe vor ungefähr fünf Jahren die Hacker School übernehmen dürfen
und seitdem konnte ich schon sehr sehr viel bewegen.
Bevor wir darauf kommen, würde ich vielleicht mal kurz erst mal bei dir bleiben wollen.
Was hat dich denn im Leben so getrieben und fasziniert, dass es dann am Ende hier in dieser Position geendet ist?
/lacht/ Also es war jetzt nicht so, dass ich schon im Kindergarten geplant hatte, mal eine Hacker School zu leiten
und Kinder für Programmieren zu begeistern, aber ich hatte einfach die Gelegenheit, sehr sehr viel im Leben auszuprobieren.
Und ich war zum Beispiel auf der Waldorfschule, ich kann also spinnen und stricken,
ich habe 30 Jahre Geige gespielt und ich habe immer die Erfahrung gemacht, dass etwas zu organisieren unglaublich viel Spaß macht.
Und mein Weg war halt einfach über wirklich viele Stationen.
Ich war 20 Jahre vorher in der Wirtschaft, ich habe eine amerikanische Eiscremekultmarke in Deutschland einführen können.
Und alleine über diese Ansätze, die wir damals gefahren sind, ist Guerillamarketing etwas, was ich ja auch gut lernen konnte
und dementsprechend kann ich da ganz ganz viel auch für die Hacker School mit hinnehmen.
Also geilen Scheiß ohne Budget machen, das habe ich schon geübt.
Das heißt, deine Skills hast du im Wesentlichen in solchen Projektmanagementebenen entwickelt?
Oder gibt es da nicht auch noch eine parallele Digitalbegeisterung?
Eine Gabe, die ich sicherlich mitbringe, ist eine hohe Begeisterungsfähigkeit, und zwar für die Sachen, die ich richtig und wichtig finde.
Und das insgesamt zu kombinieren mit einer gewissen Ausdauer und auch Standhaftigkeit,
also du spielst auch nicht ungestraft 30 Jahre Geige, an dieser Stelle nochmal danke an meine Eltern,
sie haben da wirklich heroisch ausgehalten.
Auch eine Promotion, die extern zu einer Geschäftsführung läuft, machst du halt eben auch,
naja man macht es in gewisser Hinsicht schon nebenbei, aber du brauchst halt da eine recht intensive Begeisterung für Themenfelder,
um Sachen auch wirklich abzuschließen.
Und das kombiniert mit einfach einer großen Neugierde und einer großen Liebe zu meinen Kindern,
denen ich auch wirklich einfach Zukunft zeigen möchte, ich glaube, das hat mich schon in weiten Teilen da hingebracht, wo ich jetzt bin.
Du hast was genau studiert?
Ich bin BWLerin von Haus aus.
Also ich bin keine ITlerin, aber ich habe einen geheiratet.
Ins Haus geholt sozusagen.
Insourcing ist das Stichwort.
Jetzt haben wir es ja schon angesprochen, mittlerweile bist du in diese Rolle geschlüpft, diese Hackerschule zu leiten,
vielleicht kannst du erst mal grob erzählen, worum handelt es sich dabei, seit wann gibt es das und warum gibt es das?
Hacker School wurde 2014 gegründet von drei großartigen Jungs, die das ehrenamtlich neben ihrer Geschäftsführungstätigkeit
in einer Agentur umgesetzt und ins Leben gerufen haben.
Das, was wir machen wollen, ist, eigentlich wirklich Begeisterung zu vermitteln
und Kids die Möglichkeit zu geben, neue Sachen, insbesondere Programmieren, auszuprobieren.
Weil damals, als die Hacker School gegründet wurde, hatten sie halt die Situation, sie haben Auszubildende gesucht,
für den Fachinformatiker der Anwendungsentwicklung und die jungen Menschen, die sich da beworben haben,
naja, das waren so die Kategorie, Mensch, meine Freunde haben gesagt, ich spiel doch so viel, also sollte ich vielleicht mal machen.
Und auf die Frage, hast du schon mal programmiert?
Ja, ja die ganz harten Excel vielleicht, aber ansonsten eher Google und Powerpoint.
Und das ist halt ein Satz mit X.
Und das war der Ansatz zu sagen, wer würde sich denn dafür entscheiden, sich damit auseinanderzusetzen,
wenn er oder sie wüsste, was das ist und auch wieviele Mädchen,
gut ein paar von denen mit, ich spiele doch so viel, vielleicht nicht, aber wieviele andere?
Und das ist so die Begeisterung, die sich da durchgesetzt hat.
Die ITlerinnen sind die most giving Community ever.
Also ich habe das noch nie so erlebt, diese Begeisterung, anderen etwas zu zeigen, es zu teilen, Leute mit reinzuholen.
Das ist wirklich außergewöhnlich, und das dafür zu nutzen, dass noch mehr Menschen Bock haben,
in diesem Bereich zu arbeiten, das fand ich mega überzeugend von der Idee
und da die Vision der Hacker School ist, dass jedes Kind einmal programmiert haben sollte,
bevor er oder sie sich für einen Beruf entscheidet, habe ich einfach mal gedacht, ja das nehmen wir wörtlich und das setzen wir jetzt um.
Was heißt denn Kids?
Von welchem Altersbereich sprechen wir denn jetzt?
Offizielle Zielgruppe der Hacker School ist Jungs und Mädchen zwischen 11 und 18.
Also im Sinne auch weiterführende Schule.
Also da werden jetzt keine 19-Jährigen aussortiert,
aber wirklich, dass man sagt, die Kinder oder Jugendlichen,
die in einer Phase sind, wo sie sich für einen Beruf entscheiden.
Ausnahme ist die Girls Hacker School, das sind Frauen und Mädchen 11-99,
weil wir auch einfach sehen, wenn es gut läuft, welche tolle Rolle auch Mütter bei der Berufswahl ihrer Töchter spielen können.
Und ist ja nun nicht so, dass wir zu viele Frauen in der IT hätten.
Also das da zu öffnen und auch wirklich das vielleicht als ersten Sprengsatz in der gläsernen Decke
mit Digitalfähigkeiten anzugehen, das ist halt noch eine Sonderlocke sozusagen.
Also mit 11 Jahren ist man ja jetzt nicht gerade auf Berufssuche.
Das stimmt, aber 11 Jahre ist ein geiles Alter, um Sachen auszuprobieren.
Meine Lieblinge sind 12 Jahre, die können schon gut genug lesen und schreiben
und auch ein bisschen still sitzen und ein bisschen Englisch,
um sich vielleicht auch mit so was auseinanderzusetzen und sie haben noch nicht dieses entsetzliche Fehlermindset,
was wir ja sehr sehr früh schon Kindern vermitteln.
Die rennen los, die probieren aus, die gucken sich Sachen an und wenn wir Kinder in dem Alter begeistert kriegen,
dann haben wir das mit dem hier noch eine Schulung, da noch eine Schulung überhaupt nicht mehr,
dann laufen die autodidaktisch.
Wie ist das denn jetzt sozusagen aufgestellt diese Hacker School?
Also was hat das für eine Trägerschaft, was ist das für eine Unternehmung,
was ist das für eine Rechtsform, wie zieht man so was auf?
/lacht/ Oh man hat eine sehr steile Lernkurve, egal wie man das dreht.
Ursprünglich gestartet ist die Hacker School als UG.
Zwar not for profit, aber auch nicht gemeinnützig.
Dann ging es um eine Förderung der Stadt Hamburg aus dem Integrationsfond damals.
Dann brauchten wir eine Gemeinnützigkeit, dann wurde der i3 e. V. gegründet,
weil dem Vereinsregister Hamburg war der Hacker School e. V. zu kriminell.
Das fanden die irgendwie, klang so ein bisschen putzig.
Ausgerechnet in Hamburg.
Ja, weißt du, es gibt da immer sone und solche.
Aber dann gab es halt diesen i3 e. V. die Initiative Informatikinspiration.
Aber mit zunehmendem Wachstum wurde das etwas komplizierter.
Weil wenn du halt sechsstellig Gelder von Stiftungen einsammelst
und die sagen, Moment die Hacker School ist ein Projekt des i3 e. V.
und hä wir wollen aber nicht den, wir wollen nur die Hacker School.
Da habe ich gesagt, wenn ich das jetzt wirklich wirklich groß machen soll
und jedes Kind in Deutschland heißt, wir haben 6,5 Millionen Kids zwischen 11 und 18 ungefähr,
da müssen wir mal ordentlich reinhauen.
Und da kann nicht so was wie, ich muss die Rechtsform erklären, einfach nicht mehr brauchen.
Und dann fiel die Entscheidung, die Rechte von der uG zu übernehmen
und durch Rechtsnachfolge den i3 e. V. in eine gGmbH in die Hacker School gGmbH umzuwandeln
und ja das sind wir jetzt, wir sind eine gemeinnützige gGmbH.
Wir sind vier Gesellschafter, ich halte 51%, die anderen Gesellschafter jeweils 16.
Und wir haben es auch so gemacht, dass die Anteile nicht veräußert werden können,
wenn einer rausgeht, bleiben die Anteile drin und es wechselt.
Also es ist alles so aufgebaut, dass wir ein möglichst schnelles stringentes Wachstum hinlegen können
und die Zukunft der Hacker School dadurch auch einfach rechtsformtechnisch gesichert ist.
Und in dieser Rechtsform ist es jetzt seit wann?
Seit Dezember 2020.
Okay, also noch eine relativ neue Konstruktion, aber hat sich schon bewährt?
Ja, also es ist richtig, es hat halt den Vorteil, ich bin auch alleine zeichnungsberechtigt.
Und wir hatten vorher Strukturen, wo wir immer zu zweit unterschreiben mussten,
und wenn das wirklich nur einer hauptberuflich macht und die anderen das ehrenamtlich unterstützen,
ist das einfach was, was schon auch tempotechnisch eine Herausforderung darstellt.
Und von daher, ja das hat sich soweit alles bewährt und wir laufen gut.
Wieviele Leute sind denn jetzt, wie muss man sich das jetzt vorstellen?
Also ihr habt jetzt kein großes Schulgebäude irgendwo.
Nein.
Sondern? Also was wir nicht erwähnt haben, wir sitzen jetzt auch gerade in Hamburg,
während wir das jetzt hier aufnehmen.
Das Ganze hat sozusagen Hamburg als Zentrum und das ist jetzt, sagen wir mal,
auch erstmal der schulische Bereich, in den ihr reinstrahlt.
Also wo ihr wahrscheinlich primär auch erst mal die Jugendlichen gewonnen habt.
Unterstelle ich jetzt mal so, du darfst mich gerne korrigieren.
Unterstellst du jetzt mal so.
Aber das klang ja schon an, Förderungen etc., ist ja alles nicht ganz unwichtig.
Als Arbeitshypothese, ja.
Also sagen wir, Hamburg ist unser Hometurf, das stimmt.
Und auch hier sind wir jetzt gerade bei mir im Homeoffice.
Wir haben aber auch tatsächlich die Zentrale in der Hamburger Innenstadt.
Wir sitzen jetzt im Impact Hub.
Das ist in Altona.
Wir haben vorher ein kleines Umzugstrauma hinter uns, weil wir drei Jahre in Folge jedes Jahr umgezogen sind.
Auch das letzte Büro, da wäre ich wahnsinnig gerne länger geblieben.
Wir waren bei einer wunderbaren Firma, bei Fast Forward,
die uns auch seit Jahren unterstützen, aber die sind halt so krass gewachsen,
die brauchten die Räumlichkeiten.
Dann haben wir gesagt, so ich habe keinen Bock mehr umzuziehen.
Jetzt sind wir im Impact Hub und das ist halt für uns dahingehend toll,
dass unser Team deutschlandweit verteilt ist.
Also wir haben Kollegen in Dresden, in Hannover, wir hatten eine Kollegin, die in Passau gesessen hat,
wir stellen jetzt hoffentlich in Frankfurt und NRW ein.
Also das ist halt was, wo ich Räumlichkeiten brauche, die atmen können.
Also das heißt, ein kleines Team, was in Hamburg auch gerne ins Büro geht.
Wir haben andere Kollegen in Hamburg, die eigentlich nie ins Büro gehen, dazu gehöre ich auch.
Aber dass wir da die Möglichkeit wirklich haben, wenn wir uns alle treffen wollen,
können wir da hingehen und wenn wir eben auch wirklich mit Präsenz wachsen,
kann ich auch Flächen einfach zumieten und das ist eine sehr praktische Sache.
Also Impact Hub ist so ein Coworking Space, ich weiß gar nicht, ob das schon ausreicht heutzutage,
es hat sich ja auch sehr entwickelt dieser Bereich.
Also üblicherweise hat man da viele Räume, wenn man mal einen Konferenzraum braucht,
dann nimmt man den sich, aber wenn man den nicht braucht, dann benutzen den eben andere.
Schon vier Etagen, also das ist recht groß und das sind halt wirklich Impact Startups,
die sich auch gegenseitig befruchten, wo wir coole Menschen kennenlernen können,
wo es tolle Veranstaltungen gibt, also ist schon ein cooler Laden.
Deine andere Arbeitshypothese, wir würden nur Hamburg machen, die würde ich so nochmal aufarbeiten.
Ich habe nicht nur gesagt.
/lacht/ Nein.
Ich habe nur gesagt, das ist so ein bisschen das, wo es entsteht und sein Zentrum hat.
Wir testen hier alles aus.
Weil es ist mega, wenn du wirklich vor der Haustür pilotieren kannst.
Wir waren vor Corona schon in 40 Städten deutschlandweit aktiv,
wo wir bei den Unternehmen vor Ort Kurse veranstaltet haben.
Und es ist jetzt so, dass wir eben weiterhin mit diesem…
also wir sind jetzt seit Anfang letzten Jahres mit diesen beiden großen Säulen unterwegs,
also die außerschulischen Kurse, oft in den Unternehmen teilweise online,
aber die innerschulischen Kurse als zweites wirklich großes Standbein,
wo wir mit ganzen Klassen einen Vormittag programmieren.
Wo die Kids in den Klassen vor Ort sind und wir als ITlerinnen schalten uns zu.
Das zieht sich ebenfalls schon über die ganze Republik.
Es ist natürlich so, dass man, ich sage mal, den steilen Lerneffekt wirklich auch regional lokal teilweise macht.
Also einfach zu sagen, hey wir brauchen zehn Schulen in Berlin, wer will noch mal, wer hat noch nicht?
Das haut überhaupt nicht hin.
Aber die Möglichkeit zu haben, hier in Hamburg über eine Kombination mit der Arbeitsagentur,
der Wirtschaftsbehörde und der Schulbehörde.
Auch in Schulleiterkonferenzen präsentieren zu können und dadurch eben halt einfach auch Zugänge zu lernen
und insbesondere mit wenig Geld die Welt retten zu wollen, da musst du optimieren,
da musst du gucken, wie kommst du von A nach B, wer kann dir Türen öffnen?
Und wie können wir vielleicht noch mehr Kinder erreichen?
Das ist halt etwas, da musst du viele Sachen ausprobieren und da haben wir in Hamburg die meisten Erfahrungen gesammelt,
aber können noch ganz viel davon auf andere Bundesländer übertragen.
Okay, jetzt hast du gesagt, es gibt innerschulische, außerschulische Kurse,
vielleicht kannst du das noch mal so ein bisschen aufdröseln, wie eigentlich das Angebot dieser Hacker School ist.
Also wenn ich das jetzt so richtig verstanden habe, es gibt sowohl die Möglichkeit,
einfach sich frei auf irgendwelche Kurse zu bewerben und dann macht man da mit
und dann ist vollkommen egal, in welchem schulischen Kontext man unterwegs ist
und es gibt aber auch explizit eine Zusammenarbeit mit kompletten Klassen im Rahmen des normalen Schulunterrichts oder angebunden daran?
Genau.
Ja?
Also die Hacker School kommt halt eben ursprünglich aus der Ecke, dass es darum ging,
wirklich ehrenamtliche ITler in Unternehmen so zu unterstützen,
dass die eben halt ein Wochenende mit Kindern geilen Scheiß machen können.
Wirklich begeistern, spielen, Zukunft entdecken und halt nichts beibringen.
Aber die lernen dabei wahnsinnig viel.
Und dieser Unternehmenskontext der ist toll, der ist super.
wir haben halt die ehrenamtlichen ITler, die das machen, teilweise in ihrer Arbeitszeit, teilweise am Wochenende.
Wir sehen aber, dass wir damit die Verantwortung bei den Kindern belassen.
Sie müssen sich dafür interessieren, sie müssen sich dafür entscheiden
oder sie brauchen Eltern, die für sie entscheiden, dass sie sich da jetzt mal hinbewegen.
Und wenn wir die Hacker School wirklich auch dafür nutzen wollen,
dass wir IT, dass wir digitale Bildung integrativ sehen, dass wir jedes Kind erreichen wollen,
müssen wir für Mädchen und auch sozioökonomisch benachteiligte Kinder teilweise die Extrameile gehen.
Und in den Schulklassen kriegen wir sie nahezu alle.
Und da haben wir halt einfach das Setting, wenn wir mit den ganzen Schulklassen programmieren,
haben wir die, die schon denken, sie sind die Helden, was nicht unbedingt immer zutrifft
und wir haben die, die denken, sie brechen sich, sobald sie in die Nähe einer Tastatur kommen, mindestens zwei Fingernägel ab.
Und wir brauchen drei Stunden, um genau diesen Prozess von, brich mir keinen Fingernagel ab,
zu, boah macht das Spaß, das wirklich zu durchleben.
Und das ist das Tolle, dass wir in den Schulklassen zwar auch die Kids haben,
die erst mal keinen Bock haben, aber wenn wir die geknackt kriegen,
ist das etwas, was unglaublich begeistert.
Und das sind eben halt jetzt die ganz großen beiden Säulen, mit denen wir arbeiten.
Wie läuft denn das konkret ab, vielleicht kannst du das ja mal schildern?
Jetzt so von, also wer fängt da an?
Ihr sprecht Schulen an, Schulen sprechen euch an?
Wie rum geht das, sowohl als auch oder primär in die eine Richtung?
Kommt darauf an.
Also es gibt nichts, was es nicht gibt grundsätzlich.
Aber wir merken, dass wir insbesondere durch so was wie, ich präsentiere auf einer Schulleiterkonferenz
oder eine Schule empfiehlt uns der anderen, einfach viel viel schneller sind
als wenn wir eine Schule anrufen und sagen, hallo wir sind die Hacker School.
Das ist erst mal was, …
Also Schulleiterkonferenz sozusagen so schulübergreifend, wo sich Schulleiter treffen
und über ihre Probleme sprechen.
Ja oder wo es Informationen gibt.
Also hier in Fluch und Segen eines Stadtstaats, das ist eindeutig einer von den segensreicheren Seiten,
es gibt für die Gymnasien und es gibt für die Stadtteilschulen, das sind hier unsere beiden großen Schulformen,
die wir hier haben, jeweils, ich weiß gar nicht in welchem Abstand, aber immer wieder Konferenzen,
wo alle Schulleitungen zusammenkommen.
Und da gibt die Schulbehörde Infos raus.
Da werden, was weiß ich, zum Beispiel wenn der Schwerpunkt berufliche Bildung ist,
kommen halt auch Leute von der Arbeitsagentur, um da auch Sachen mit vorzustellen
und da durfte ich halt eben auch in dem Kontext berufliche Bildung bzw. Berufsorientierung eben halt vorstellen,
was wir mit der Hacker School machen, was wir brauchen, was wir anbieten können, wie das hier funktioniert.
Und danach sind sehr viele Schule auf uns zugekommen.
Und genau diese Wege zu finden, das funktioniert in einem Stadtstaat ganz anders als in einem Flächenland.
Aber da zu gucken, mit wem muss man sprechen, mit wem sollte man nicht sprechen,
was sind die informellen Wege, wie man eben genauso an Schulen kommt,
da haben wir einen echt guten Job gemacht und also wir haben mehr Schulen,
die uns anfragen, als wir im Moment befriedigen können, in dem Sinne,
weil die andere Seite, wir müssen ja die ITlerinnen, die mit uns diese Kurse machen.
Da haben wir zwar jetzt auch richtig gut gearbeitet und setzen auch neue Konzepte auf,
wo wir insbesondere über Corporate Volunteering auch auf die Auszubildenden zugreifen können und wollen,
aber das ist eben einfach was, wo wir wirklich zusehen müssen,
wenn ich nächstes Jahr 25.000 Kinder erreichen möchte, weil wir verdoppeln jedes Jahr,
dann brauche ich dafür 4000-5000 ITlerinnen und die kannst du dir nicht backen.
Und da die Wege zu kriegen, das ist im Moment der limitierende Faktor.
Okay, dann bleiben wir noch mal ganz kurz bei dieser Schule, weil ich wollte einfach so diese Anbahnung mal verstehen.
Also jetzt Schulleiterkonferenz mal als Beispiel, ja ist relativ effizient.
Mit anderen Worten, man erreicht erst mal Schulleiter oder vielleicht deren unmittelbares Personal,
die ja dann vielleicht ja auch noch da daran teilnehmen und dann sagen die so,
ahja okay alles klar, klingt ja ganz interessant, könnte was für uns sein.
Und dann geben die das an Lehrer, Fachlehrer weiter, Klassenlehrer weiter?
Also wie läuft da dann konkret so eine Zusammenarbeit ab?
Ganz häufig sind es wirklich die Fachlehrer.
Es läuft sehr sehr viel über Berufsorientierung, weil einige der Fachlehrerinnen
oder die meisten Schulen haben auch einen Beauftragten für Berufsorientierung.
In Hamburg ist es zumindest verpflichtend, aber ich meine, dass es in anderen Bundesländern auch so ist.
Und da wird einfach gesagt, hey im Rahmen dessen, wir brauchen einen Vormittag,
wir wollen drei Stunden programmieren, wir stellen Berufe vor, wann passt das?
Und wir setzen dann den Schwerpunkt achte Klasse aufwärts,
einfach weil da die Berufsorientierung tatsächlich schon konkreter ist als bei Elfjährigen, da hast du recht.
Und da sind die Kids offener, da hören sie zu und da wird dann nach Terminen gesucht.
Wir versuchen meistens, mindestens vier Klassen auf einmal an einer Schule zu kriegen.
Nicht an einem Tag, weil da sind die Computerräume wieder eng,
aber dass eben der Anbahnungsprozess mit einer einzelnen Schule sich auf mehr Kinder verteilt,
haben wir eben halt die Entscheidung da getroffen, da wo möglich ist,
ist schon schön, wenn wir mit 100 Kindern an einer Schule programmieren können.
Und greifen da jetzt alle Schularten, also sowohl Gymnasien als auch Gesamtschulen?
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das in Hamburg alles heißt.
Hamburg haben wir Stadtteilschulen und Gymnasien.
Also alle allgemeinbindenden Schulen, bei denen die Kinder nicht über extragroße Herausforderungen limitiert sind, funktionieren gut.
Also was nicht so super hinhaut, dadurch dass wir in Hamburg einen sehr intensiven Ansatz fahren,
haben wir auf den Förderschulen, die es gibt, Kinder mit einem so großen Förderbedarf,
dass das mit, sitz am Rechner und ich erkläre dir was und du verstehst es
und du kannst dich artikulieren, dass das da nun nicht mehr im Durchschnitt möglich ist.
Und das ist was, das trauen wir uns nicht zu, zumindest Stand heute nicht.
Es ist auch so, dass wir bei einigen Brennpunktschulen sehen, dass wir da mit dem Hacker School at your school plus,
ein Sonderprojekt, das wir da auch noch mal über andere Ansätze nachdenken müssen,
weil insbesondere bei Schulen mit einem sehr niedrigen Sozialindex, in Hamburg sind die Schulen indiziert.
Also 6 ist mega Sozialindex, was ich am Einkommen der Eltern,
aber auch an Muttersprachlichkeit und noch einigen anderen Faktoren festmacht,
1 ist schwieriges Niveau und dass wir da eben halt sehen, dass wir mit dem Sozialindex 1 und 2 tatsächlich auch über ein Vorortformat nachdenken
bzw. gerade eine Erprobung in Erwägung ziehen, wie wir auch da über virtuelles Zuschalten arbeiten können,
aber da müssen wir noch mal die Extrameile gehen.
Okay, kommen wir noch mal zurück auf die Anbahnung so.
Also jetzt gibt es diesen Kontakt mit den Fachlehrerinnen
und die sagen, okay prima, das würden wir jetzt ganz gerne mal hier in dieser Klasse
oder in jener Klasse oder in mehreren Klassen vielleicht auch machen
und dann einigt man sich quasi auf einen Termin und dann werden mal drei Stunden aus dem normalen Schulprogramm frei gemacht.
Sehe ich das richtig?
Ja, es wird teilweise auf die Schulstundentaktung angepasst.
Das heißt, da, wo es möglich ist, wird es so eingestielt, dass es mit den Pausen,
den normalen Pausen d’accord geht.
Bei anderen ist es wirklich dann 9-13 Uhr.
Da kommen die Kinder halt ein bisschen später.
Also d gibt es unterschiedliche Variante.
Aber wir fragen immer vier Stunden an, weil drei Stunden wird programmiert,
bisschen Pause, Gruppeneinteilung und so weiter,
aber wir wollen auch immer noch einen anteiligen halbe Stunde,
manchmal auch 25 Minuten dafür haben, dass die ITlerInnnen, die mit uns die Kurse geben,
ihre Berufe vorstellen können, ganz wichtiger Teil.
Und so gesehen, ja wir fragen immer vier Stunden an und die werden unterschiedlich gelegt.
Und was wird den Kindern dann quasi gesagt, was dann stattfinden soll?
Wie kündigt ihr das an, was ist sozusagen ein bisschen das, also ist alles Überraschung
oder gibt es da irgendwie konkrete…
/lacht/
Naja, ist ja dann wahrscheinlich auch die Frage, wie man das so von vornherein erst mal framt,
um nicht gleich Desinteresse auszulösen oder Abwehrverhalten,
keine Ahnung, wie da die Befindlichkeiten sind.
Und meistens ist es ja so mit, hier noch mehr Dinge, die ihr lernen sollt,
wo ihr schon ohnehin euch ein bisschen überfordert fühlt.
Kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass es auch eine gewisse Abwehrreaktion geben kann.
Muss man ja sicherlich auch alles richtig ankündigen.
Es ist tatsächlich so, dass wir auch im Moment noch da dran sind zu arbeiten,
wie wir die Lehrenden mit ins Boot kriegen.
Weil die Kinder sind tatsächlich gar nicht so die Herausforderung.
Bitcom hat wieder eine Studie herausgebracht, wo, ich glaube, 75 Prozent der Kids mittlerweile sagen,
ja wir wollen digitale Skills lernen, das ist wichtig, wir wollen da mal reingucken.
Bei den Lehrenden liegt das ein kleines bisschen drunter.
Und da wirklich…
Also denen auf der Schule?
Ja.
Da auch den Lehrenden die Sorgen zu nehmen, dass es überhaupt nicht darum geht,
dass sie was können müssen oder dass da irgendjemand vorgeführt werden soll,
sondern dass wir einfach die Kinder beim Entdecken unterstützen wollen
und das mit eben halt Jungs und Mädels, die das richtig können und die das richtig gerne mögen, das klappt gut.
Also meistens wird das wirklich als ein Projekttag angekündigt
oder wirklich als eine Möglichkeit, Berufsorientierung zu erproben.
Weil es ist genau so ein bisschen wie beim Geige spielen,
nur weil du Geigenmusik gerne hörst, heißt das nicht, dass du ein Talent zum Spielen hast.
Aber es auszuprobieren und wirklich mal zu sehen, boah das geht ja viel besser als ich das dachte.
Insbesondere bei Mädels sehen wir, die kriegen wir hinterher gar nicht wieder ab vom Rechner.
Aber auf jeden Fall das, aktuell hängt es noch tatsächlich an der Lehrkraft, wie sie das auch mit weitergibt.
Da sind wir noch dabei, auch Wege zu erproben, wie wir die Lehrenden noch enger mit einbinden können.
Ja gut, aber wie wird es angekündigt, also was sagt ihr den Kindern?
Es finden vier Stunden statt und ihr sollt programmieren lernen.
Ja, hier kommen echte Hacker zu euch und machen einen Vormittag mit euch.
Wenn wir gut sind und die Lehrenden dazu kriegen, das zu sagen, dann sagen die,
die machen den Vormittag mit euch geilen Scheiß.
Ein kleiner Teil von mir bezweifelt, dass die wirklich geilen Scheiß sagen, so was tun Lehrer nicht.
Aber es wird eben angekündigt, ihr habt die Möglichkeit, selber mal zu programmieren.
Es gibt unterschiedliche Themen, mit denen wir arbeiten, bzw. unterschiedliche Programmiersprachen.
Und dass dann eben gesagt wird, mit Python oder mit html könnt ihr eine kleine Webseite bauen.
Es geht einfach drum, es wird nicht bewertet, das wird auch häufig mit dazu gesagt,
weil das bei den Kindern unglaublich Druck rausnimmt.
Und es ist einfach eure Zeit, guckt euch das an, Berufe anschauen war noch nie so einfach.
Genau, aber der Beruf, der angeschaut wird, ist sozusagen der Beruf des Programmierens.
Und darum geht es im Wesentlichen und im Kern und vor allem.
Weil ich meine, wenn man sagt, digitales Lernen, kann es ja alles mögliche sein.
Hier geht es schon konkret auch ums Coding, das steht bei euch im Mittelpunkt?
Ja, es geht immer drum, dass die Kids das ausprobieren.
Den Beruf nur Programmierer den gibt es ja auch selbst in zig Ausführungen.
Lustig, weil ich habe neulich den Namen eines schönen Ausbildungsberufes gehört,
Matse, mathematisch technischer Softwareentwickler, ist ja auch was schönes.
Es gibt die Fachinformatiker für Systemintegration, Hardware bzw. Anwendungsentwicklung,
ist ja viel mit Programmieren.
Worum es uns geht ist tatsächlich, dass die Kids selber mal hinter den Bildschirm gucken und selbst sehen,
was ist algorithmisches Denken, wie „rede“ ich mit Maschinen
und dass sie auch selber diese Erfahrung mache der Selbstwirksamkeit.
Dass sie selber da etwas hinkriegen, was sie sich vorher nicht zugetraut haben
und dass das Connect zu einer grundsätzlichen Fähigkeit gibt,
wenn auch nicht zu einem einzelnen Berufsbild.
Und wir vermitteln dadurch die 21th Century Skills bzw. eine Erfahrung davon,
dass sie Probleme, die sie nicht kennen, kreativ und kommunikativ lösen müssen
in Zusammenarbeit mit anderen mit kritischem Denken und dass sie halt eben auch sehen,
dass es total geil ist, Fehler zu machen, weil man dadurch sehr viele Sachen direkt rausfinden kann und ausschließen.
Aber jetzt, um mal den Bogen kurz abzuschließen, dann findet dieser vier Stunden Block statt
und dann ist das sozusagen auch damit erst mal abgeschlossen.
Also das ist sozusagen ein Event, der stattfindet und dann wird einfach geguckt,
okay was löst das jetzt aus, und was löst es dann aus?
Also was ist so euer Erfahrungsspektrum, was das dann so auslöst?
Und inwiefern habt ihr dann mit den Kindern später noch zu tun?
Da wir ein großes Interesse daran haben, unsere Wirkung belegen zu können,
weil Wirkung ist auch das Marketing der Sozialorganisation.
Wir müssen zeigen, wieviel Gramm leuchtende Kinderaugen wir pro eingesetzten Euro rauskriegen.
Fragen wir immer direkt nach den Veranstaltungen.
Also wir haben Evaluationsbogen, wo wir wirklich sehen, dass die Kinder auch sagen können,
habe ich dadurch ein besseres Verständnis für IT-Berufe?
Ja, die meisten haben das.
Ob es Spaß gemacht hat, auch, weil man sieht ja, dass insbesondere wenn mir etwas Freude macht,
bin ich auch bereit, mich da für Veränderungen zu öffnen, wenn ich etwas ablehne, bin ich direkt verschlossen.
Und da wirklich zu sagen, habe ich eine bessere Idee, was Digitalisierung,
was Programmieren eigentlich ist, kann ich mir dadurch ein besseres Bild über die Berufswelt machen?
Kann ich dadurch vielleicht auch eher wahrnehmen, dass es auch für mich als Mädchen etwas spannendes sein kann?
Das sind Sachen, die wir abfragen.
Und wir sehen in dem Kontext eben auch, dass dadurch, dass wir die Kids bei uns haben,
die vorher noch nichts damit zu tun hatten, dass es da sehr große Überraschungsmomente gibt.
Und teilweise bedauern wir das auch, dass wir das nicht eins zu eins zuordnen können.
Weil die Kinder in den Schulen sind für uns in der achten Klasse alle 14
und haben die Postleitzahl der Schule.
Wir haben die Verteilung von Jungs und Mädels, weil danach häufig gefragt wird,
aber darüber hinaus haben wir keine Daten der Kinder.
Das ist ein Opfer, was ich bereit bin zu bringen, vor dem Hintergrund,
dass wir dadurch nicht in größere Kollision mit dem Datenschutz kommen.
Und bevor wir von jedem Elternteil unterschreiben lassen, dass das Kind sich bei uns anmelden darf,
da sind wir ja mit jeder Schule drei Monate beschäftigt,
ist das der Preis, den ich bereit bin zu bezahlen und wir sehen einfach,
dass dieser disruptive Impuls, wie Stiftungen das nennen, den wir da setzen,
dass der seine Wirkung zeigt, weil wir auch in den außerschulischen Kursen immer mehr Kids haben,
die angeben mit, wo habt ihr uns kennengelernt, ah ja ihr wart bei uns in der Schule.
Und da sehen wir eben auch schon die ersten Zusammenhänge, wie sich das weiterentwickelt.
Vielleicht noch mal zu dem Format, also die Leute, die diese Kurse dann gestalten,
du sprichst von Freiwilligen, wo kommen die her, wieviele, was habt ihr da sozusagen für einen…
Also wieviele Kinder nehmen denn daran teil, also an so einer Session,
wieviele Personen stehen quasi auf der anderen Seite?
Was habt ihr da für einen Schlüssel, mit dem ihr arbeitet?
Wir arbeiten mit dem Verhältnis 1:6.
Also außerschulisch auch meistens, aber innerschulisch ist es immer das Verhältnis 1:6 ungefähr.
Kommt drauf an, wieviele Kinder in einer Klasse sind.
Das heißt, bei 24 Kids haben wir vier Inspirer, die die Kurse geben, plus ein Team-Inspirer bei mir aus dem Team,
der den Kurs leitet, alles vorstellt, unterstützt, durch die Räume geht, bei Fragen zur Verfügung steht.
Einfach dass diejenigen, die die Kurse geben, sich da auch rundum wohl und gut betreut fühlen.
Und diejenigen, die die Kurse geben, kriegen wir eben halt insbesondere über Corporate Volunteering aus Unternehmen.
Weil IT-Lehrer backen hat sich noch nicht als besonders gutes Mittel herausgestellt.
Deswegen fragen wir ganz häufig Azubis an oder wir bitten Unternehmen um Unterstützung durch Corporate Volunteers,
immer mit dem Hinweis, dass es uns begeistert, wirklich dass wir sehr begeistert sind,
wenn wir Azubis kriegen, weil die gerade die Entscheidung getroffen haben, wo sie hin wollen,
weil die viel näher dran sind an den Kids als keine Ahnung, auch Leute, die 30-40 Jahre in dem Beruf arbeiten.
Das ist auch großartig, jede helfende Hand ist willkommnen.
Aber tatsächlich zu sagen, dass Azubis, die auch hinsichtlich Opportunitätskosten für einen Betrieb
auch möglicherweise etwas günstiger sind als ein hochbezahlter ITler.
Das ist auch noch mal ein Argument zusätzlich zu dem Punkt, dass man sieht,
wieviel diese jungen Menschen bei uns lernen können, dadurch dass sie die Kurse geben,
dass sie zielgruppenadäquate Kommunikation praktizieren, dass sie lernen durch lehren,
dass sie IT für nicht ITler erklären, dass sie einfach lernen, in Situationen,
wo sie sich erstmal vielleicht so ein bisschen putzig fühlen, gut zu agieren und ihre Punkte zu machen.
Das ist etwas, da nehmen die so viel draus mit und das den Azubis zu ermöglichen,
die haben mindestens so viel davon wie die Kids, das ist also tatsächlich für alle Beteiligten eine win-win-win-Situation.
Setzt ihr da jetzt allein auf Learning by Doing oder gibt es dann auch in gewisser Hinsicht so eine Art begleitendes Coaching?
Weil ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen, dass es gerade so in Nerdkreisen, machen wir uns nichts vor,
sind vielleicht die pädagogischen Fähigkeiten dann nicht unbedingt immer so von Natur aus ausgeprägt.
Für manche mag das ja auch schwierig sein, dann sich überhaupt in so eine Situation zu begeben.
Wie begleitet ihr das?
Habt ihr da nochmal einen Kurs für die Freiwilligen?
Train the Trainer.
Ja, train the Trainer, findet das statt oder?
Ergibt sich das von alleine?
Unbedingt.
Also wir machen die Erfahrung, wenn die Leute sich wohlfühlen, dann sind sie am allerbesten.
Und insbesondere auch junge Menschen, wenn wir denen die Unsicherheit nehmen können,
dann laufen die zu Hochform auf.
Wir haben Kurse vorbereitet, die Konzepte stehen also, insbesondere für den Schulbereich.
Wir verteilen die Kurskonzepte, dass die sich vorher angeguckt werden können,
wir machen Onboardings, wo sowohl zu den Konzepten als auch zu how to handle kids viele Fragen gestellt werden können.
Und wir haben die ganze Zeit ein Team-Inspirer mit dabei, der selber halt keine Kinder hat,
sondern sich wirklich um alle anderen mit kümmern kann.
Dass ich davon überzeugt bin, dass die Menschen, die mit uns zusammen die Kurse geben,
richtig gut vorbereitet da reingehen und auch wenn sie dann eben halt dann beim Tun selber noch Fragen haben,
ist auch immer jemand an ihrer Seite.
Und das sind dann Personen, die Angestellte oder Mitarbeiter der Hacker School sind,
die da sozusagen noch mal so diese Metateilnahme durchführen
oder sind das auch nur irgendwelche anderen Freiwilligen, die schon länger dabei sind?
Nein, ich habe mittlerweile ein Team von 35 Leuten ungefähr auf der Payroll,
davon ist gut ein Dutzend die sind Team-Inspirer, das sind Minijobber, Werkstudenten,
unterschiedliche Vertragskonstruktionen, die teilweise schon seit mehreren Jahren bei der Hacker School mit unterstützen
und die tatsächlich die Kurse leiten und dadurch eben halt auch ein sehr sehr großes Erfahrungswissen haben,
worauf sie eben halt auch noch mal Ruhe mit ausstrahlen können.
Jetzt sollten wir vielleicht auch nochmal kurz auf dieses außerschulische Angebot eingehen,
weil das war ja jetzt sozusagen alles die …
Gut, da wird sich ja wahrscheinlich viel wiederholen, aber im Prinzip ist es ja erst mal was anderes,
allein schon deshalb, weil die Kids sich ja da quasi selber initiativ bewerben
oder von irgendjemandem da hingeschoben werden, was auch immer da der Trigger jetzt ist so.
Aber du hast ja schon gesagt, nicht selten sind es dann eben auch Kids,
die es einfach in der Schule so durch diesen Erstkontakt mitbekommen haben und festgestellt haben so,
oh funktioniert ja eigentlich ganz gut für mich, interessiert mich, würde ich gerne noch mal machen.
Was habt ihr dann da im Angebot und dann habt ihr ja in dem Sinne keine Schule,
wo ihr das machen könnt, wo findet das dann und wie findet das dann statt?
Ja, das ist auch tatsächlich ein kleines bisschen freier gestaltet.
Also das ist das, wo die Hacker School herkommt, wo auch wirklich Begeisterung der ITlerInnen transportiert wird,
auch teilweise die Gedanken, die sie selber haben, mit umzusetzen.
Also in dem Sinne, wir gehen davon aus, wenn jemand für ein Thema brennt,
kann er das am besten vermitteln.
Und außerschulische Kurse sind halt thementechnisch nochmal deutlich freier.
Das heißt, wenn jemand einen Line Follower Robot machen möchte
oder doch mal mit JavaScript zum Beispiel in Minecraft was bauen möchte oder sonst was,
ist das schon möglich, wir haben auch da so Rahmendaten für, wie baue ich eigentlich einen Kurs auf,
wie sollte das optimalerweise auch von der Schrittigkeit vorangehen,
aber es ist letztendlich viel freier, weil jeder auch seine Gedanken mit einbringen kann.
Und das Spannende daran ist, die Kurse sind halt doppelt so lang.
Wenn wir vor Ort in Unternehmen sind, sind es sogar zweimal fünf Stunden,
weil man sich zuerst die Kurse noch mit aussuchen kann und am Ende eine Präsentation hat,
wo man selber seine Projekte darstellen kann.
Wenn wir es online machen, sind es zweimal vier Stunden, weil online immer ein bisschen verdichtet ist,
weil das hat eine andere Intensität, weil vor Ort machen die Kinder auch mal Quatsch zusammen
und so weiter, das ist online ein bisschen strukturierter.
Aber da haben wir eben den großen Vorteil, dass Kinder auch Unternehmen nochmal viel besser kennenlernen können.
Also vor der Pandemie waren wir zum Beispiel viermal im Jahr bei Otto hier in Hamburg auf dem Campus.
Die haben einen so tollen Coworking Space, das Collaborate, da waren wir mit bis zu 100 Kindern
und das war tierisch laut und super anstrengend und wir haben auch so viel zusammen gelernt.
Das erste Mal hatten sie noch Fritz Cola hingestellt und sechs wirklich hohe Berge Schokolade
und wo wir hinterher eigentlich, ich war schon kurz davor, nach Panzertape zu fragen,
um die Kinder auf den Stühlen festzuhalten, aber das war mega,
eine unglaublich also tolle Erfahrung auch für die Kids, wo die eben halt sehen,
wow, also viele waren vorher noch nie in einem Unternehmen.
Und das macht eben halt auch noch mal einen ganz großen Reiz aus,
dass dadurch auch noch mal wirklich eine klarere Idee entsteht, was kann ich hier eigentlich auch beruflich machen?
Und man sagt ja immer, der Raum ist der vierte Pädagoge sozusagen.
Das ist natürlich was, das geht halt nur vor Ort.
Ich bin trotzdem super stolz, dass wir auch online richtig gute Kurse machen können.
Da müssen wir einen anderen Weg finden, dass eben halt auch die Unternehmen gut zeigen können,
was eigentlich junge Menschen bei ihnen lernen können.
Aber es ist letztendlich einfach was, der Fokus liegt da drauf,
wirklich diese Begeisterung zu wecken und den geilen Scheiß zu machen sozusagen
und da ist halt einfach außerschulisch noch ein bisschen mehr Zeit als an einem Projektvormittag sozusagen,
aber ich glaube, das ist auch dahingehend ein guter Aufbau.
Weil wenn wir in den Schulen vier Stunden mit Kids arbeiten, die wirklich wirklich echt nicht wollen,
was auch mal passieren kann, die lernen trotzdem eine Menge.
Aber das ist halt so von der Größenordnung was, das kann man noch gut aushalten.
Das kann man wirklich gut machen.
Daraus zwei Tage in den Schulen zu machen, das wäre mir nicht sinnvoll vorgekommen.
Aber denjenigen Kindern, die dann auch wirklich Lust haben weiterzumachen,
das als einen Zwischenschritt anzubieten, dass sie da auch nochmal tiefer in Projekte eintauchen können,
da haben wir einfach super Erfahrungen mit gemacht.
Das heißt, wenn ich das richtig verstehe, diese offline außerschulischen Sachen
finden dann aber auch immer bei irgendwelchen Unternehmen in gestellten Räumen statt oder?
Ja, also entweder sie sind online oder sie sind halt eben bei Unternehmen,
weil wir haben selber gar keine eigenen Räumlichkeiten.
Die das dann kostenlos zur Verfügung stellen?
Ja. Wir bringen meist die Hardware mit, weil die wenigsten haben, wenn die was weiß ich,
drei, vier Kurse anbieten, die wenigsten haben 30 Schulungsrechner tagesaktuell aufgesetzt,
da helfen wir im Zweifelsfall aus.
Die Kids arbeiten dann im Pairprogramming, also sie teilen sich einen Rechner,
aber die Räumlichkeiten werden von den Unternehmen gestellt.
Auch gerne mal, also bitte keine Fritz Cola, aber eben halt ein bisschen Snacks, Getränke, das machen die auch gerne.
Und eben halt insbesondere die Inspirer, die die Kurse geben und wir unterstützen halt überall wo sie es brauchen.
Und die Aufgaben suchen sich die Kids selber aus, denken die sich selber aus
oder habt ihr sozusagen so ein Set von Sachen mit, hier das könntet ihr machen,
was interessiert euch, also wie findet sich sozusagen der Inhalt letzten Endes?
Wir haben es, wenn wir vor Ort Kurse in Unternehmen machen, in der Regel zwei oder drei unterschiedliche Kurse, die parallel laufen.
Und da ist es so, dass diese Kurse am Anfang der Session vorgestellt werden
und die Kids sich dann vor Ort aussuchen können, was sie im Detail machen möchten.
Also wir sorgen schon für eine Gleichverteilung.
Kannst du mal ein Beispiel nennen, was das so wäre so bei drei, vier Angeboten?
Zum Beispiel, bau eine Webseite, bau ein Spiel mit Python.
Wir hatten neulich das mit, druck dir eine Drohne aus sozusagen.
Das war natürlich auch ein Highlight.
Oder bau einen Daddeltisch mit einer Mateteebox.
Also ganz unterschiedliche Sachen.
Die großen Jungs und Mädels werden ja auch nicht erwachsen.
Also teilweise je bekloppter die Idee, desto größer die Learnings.
Aber da haben wir ganz ganz vielfältige Sachen.
Okay, aber es gibt sozusagen, man bietet was an und die Kids entscheiden sich dann für eins davon
und das wird dann eben fokussiert gemacht, sodass man es eben auch entsprechend vorbereiten kann.
Genau.
Weil es gibt ja, wirst du ja sicherlich auch kennen, so Projekte wie Jugend hackt,
die ein ähnliches Ziel haben, also Kreativität und Hackertum Jugendlichen näher zu bringen,
die aber dann eben auch sehr drauf stehen, dass die Kids dann auch noch ihre eigenen Ideen mitbringen
und die dann irgendwie dynamisch begleitet werden.
Wollte ich nur mal ein bisschen aussortieren, wie euer Ansatz da an der Stelle ist.
Ja, Code und Design macht das ja ähnlich, die sind sogar noch länger als Jugend hackt,
die sind ja sogar vier Tage mit dabei.
Also wir sagen immer gerne, wir sind so die kleine Schwesterorganisation von Jugend hackt.
In der Hinsicht, wir wollen alle anfixen, bei Jugend hackt hilft es tatsächlich auch schon,
ein bisschen Vorkenntnisse mitzubringen, aber die sind eben auch eine der Organisationen,
die wir immer empfehlen, sobald Kids Lust haben, auch nur ein bisschen weiterzumachen,
wir zeigen immer am Ende auch der Schulkurse mit, deine Wege in die IT.
Wenn du Bock hast, was weiter zu machen, geh hierhin, geh dahin, guck dir das an,
es ist völlig egal, was du machst, Hauptsache du tust etwas.
Und da haben wir eine ganz tolle Verweisberatung, Weiterempfehlungskultur
und die ganzen Organisationen wie Jugend hackt oder Chaos macht Schule oder ähnliches,
überall da, wo wir wirklich sagen können, schaut euch das an, guckt weiter rein, jederzeit.
Jetzt muss ich dann doch mal auf diesen Begriff noch mal kommen.
Der Hackerbegriff ist ja älter als vielleicht viele Leute denken, das ist so Ende der 60er Jahre entstanden
und hat, glaube ich, so über die Jahre sehr unterschiedlichen Zuspruch gefunden
und mediale Verarbeitung vor allem.
Da gibt es natürlich so diese naja 80er Jahre Wargames induzierte Konnotation mit so,
ja der Jugendliche auf seinem Sofa mit seinem Homecomputer und fährt dann irgendwie die Atomstäbe hoch und runter
und was weiß ich, Atomraketen werden scharf geschaltet, so die große Bedrohung aus dem Kinderzimmer.
Das war ja dann sehr populär so Hacker, das findet man ja auch medial immer wieder.
Dann natürlich auf der anderen Seite so diese konkrete Bedrohung, jetzt Cyberwar, solche Geschichten.
Während ja so die Hackerszene selber diesen Begriff immer als eine sehr kreative Bezeichnung angesehen hat.
Was habt ihr da für eine Vorstellung und warum denkst du wurde dieser Name,
da warst du ja nicht dran beteiligt, hieß doch von Anfang an Hacker School oder?
Ja.
Genau.
Warum wurde dieser Name gewählt, was verbindet ihr mit diesem Begriff?
Ich denke, das war das coolste, was man überhaupt machen konnte,
weil er so wunderbar vieldeutig ist.
Also ja, ich sollte irgendwann einmal eine Dankesrede, da hatten wir einen Preis gewonnen,
anfangen mit, Hacker, sind das nicht die Bösen?
Ja okay, haben alle gelacht.
Die Idee, warum es Hacker School genannt worden ist, ist,
dass ja in der ganzen IT-Welt ein Hack, eine unkomplizierte schnelle IT-basierte Problemlösung ist.
Und das ist das, was wir den Kids zeigen wollen, nutzt den Scheiß,
komm in den Driverseat, einfach wenn du verstehst, was du damit machen kannst
und es vielleicht ein bisschen anders anwendest, als es ursprünglich mal gedacht war,
kannst du dir das Leben viel einfacher machen.
Also mein Lieblingshack, den wir hier zu Haus haben, ist der smarte Hühnerstall.
Also wir haben drei Hühner, die trinken ganz schön viel und insbesondere im Winter nervt das wie Bolle,
wenn du permanent raus musst und das Wasser aufhacken, damit die was trinken können.
Und mit einem Microbit, der einen Temperatursensor hat, einer kleinen Heizspiralen
und drei Zeilen Code kannst du das relativ einfach machen.
Wenn Temperatur unter 0, dann starte Heizspirale, Wasser warm.
Und das ist so angenehm.
Ein Microbit ist sicherlich nie geplant worden für die Nutzung im Hühnerstall,
aber wir feiern das so, dass wir im Winter nicht raus müssen.
Und das ist das, was wir den Kids zeigen wollen, guck dir das Ding an,
verstehe wie es funktioniert und dann mach was draus, egal was, aber mach was draus.
Und das ist, natürlich haben wir ganz häufig die Nachfrage, uh kannst du mir,
setze den Namen eines Spiels ein, das Ding hacken, ich will mehr Coins oder was weiß ich was haben.
Wo wir auch immer den ethischen Jingle mit dazu machen, zu sagen,
virtuell zu stehlen ist genauso scheiße wie im wirklich wahren Leben.
Es ist völlig wurscht, verhalte dich immer so, wie du selber behandelt werden möchtest.
Und je mehr du kannst, desto größer ist deine Verantwortung, das kommt jederzeit von uns.
Einfach weil ich davon überzeugt bin, dass Wissen zu haben auch Verantwortung bedeutet.
Und das den Kids mitzugeben ist das, nicht nur weil man was kann, hat man alle Freiheiten der Welt,
sondern sollte sich immer darauf besinnen, wie man selber behandelt werden möchte.
Das ist so ein bisschen, ja, also der Name Hacker School ist eine Gesprächsaufforderung sozusagen
oder ein Angebot, genau auch über solche Sachen ins Gespräch zu kommen.
Und das ist halt eben wirklich so die Auslegung des Begriffes, den wir lieben und den wir mit der Hacker School praktizieren.
Und das findet auch statt?
Ja, genau das findet statt.
Also die Kids reflektieren sozusagen auf diesen Begriff und hinterfragen den auch?
Es gibt immer sone und solche.
Das erste ist halt immer, insbesondere pubertierende Jungs, hast du häufig diese,
kannst du mir XY hacken und ich will und so weiter.
Aber wirklich darüber zu sprechen, wie wäre es denn für dich, wenn dir deine, egal,
Daten irgendwo gemobst werden und damit Sachen gemacht werden, die dir nicht gefallen?
Es wird natürlich nie so offen zugegeben, insbesondere nicht wenn die Peergroup zuhört.
Aber man sieht, dass sich dadurch Denkprozesse in Gang setzen und dass eben auch einfach neue Sachen entstehen.
Jetzt habt ihr ja den Fokus auf Programmieren und ich glaube, was viele Leute so mit IT
oder Digitales oder so primär assoziieren im Bildungsbereich ist halt die Informatik,
das Informatikstudium, so Informatik quasi als Wissenschaft.
In gewisser Hinsicht auch sehr mathematisch.
Es gibt natürlich mittlerweile viele Ausprägungen, Studiengänge, die sehr viel gezielter,
gerade an Fachhochschulen eben auch wirklich jetzt, was du schon gesagt hast,
so Systemintegration und solche Sachen auch als Ausbildungsberufe.
Also es tut sich da eine ganze Menge, es gibt immer mehr Diversifikation.
Trotzdem habe ich gerade bei der Informatik immer so den Eindruck,
dass das Programmieren als solches gar nicht so sehr im Mittelpunkt steht.
Oder um es mal anders aufzuziehen, informatische Problemlösungen werden nicht zwangsläufig immer durch gute Programmentwicklung,
gutes Programmieren begleitet und das scheint noch so ein Konflikt zu sein,
dass es nicht so eine richtige Programmierkultur gibt oder ich frage mich manchmal,
warum es nicht einfach Studium Programmieren gibt.
Na es ist halt, glaube ich, etwas, was insbesondere for whatever reason in Deutschland sehr angstbehaftet ist.
Und es wird ja auch oft gedacht, Programmieren ist reine Mathematik.
Ja, Mathematik ist wie Sport, hilft überall.
Und es schadet auch ehrlich gesagt nichts, wenn du einkaufen gehst und dann berechnen kannst,
30 Prozent Discount was denn das jetzt eigentlich heißt?
Also von daher, ich glaube, dass wir einfach in Deutschland diese Situation haben,
dass viele Bereiche aufgrund der großen Auswahlmöglichkeiten einfach gar nicht beachtet werden.
Und das ist etwas, was ich änder möchte.
Es heißt ja nicht, nur weil ein Mädchen überhaupt nicht in Scope hat,
dass es vielleicht auch einen Beruf in der IT-Branche im weiteren Sinne spannend finden würde,
dass es das nicht kann.
Und ich möchte halt einfach wirklich diesen Scope, den junge Menschen auf potenzielle Berufe haben,
einfach deutlich erweitern.
Was sie dann im Detail machen, ist noch mal eine ganz andere Fragestellung.
Aber ich glaube, dass insbesondere, wenn sie einmal erproben zu programmieren,
dass sich dadurch ganz viele Ängste abbauen und sie einfach die Möglichkeiten anders beurteilen.
Und ich glaube auch tatsächlich, wir werden in zehn Jahren nicht mal ansatzweise mehr so programmieren wie heute.
Wenn du dir anguckst, welche Lowcodevariante alle im Kommen sind, ist das noch mal eine ganz andere Fragestellung.
Aber ich glaube, dass wir viel viel mehr Leute brauchen, die in Erwägung ziehen,
sich in diesem Bereich mündig beruflich zu engagieren.
Wenn wir das nicht hinkriegen wird das ziemlich eng.
Und das möchte ich halt eben erreichen dadurch, dass wir die Begeisterung für Programmieren einfach mal durch das praktische Erfahren wecken.
So Projekte wie die Hacker School stehen natürlich auch jetzt deshalb so ein bisschen im Interesse,
auch des Stifterverbands und es wurde ja dann auch in entsprechenden Projekten auch schon gewürdigt,
weil wir einfach ja generell so ein Ausbildungsproblem haben in dem, was man so schön als MINT bezeichnet.
Also Schwerpunkt Mathematik, Informatik, generell naturwissenschaftliche Fächer bzw. technische Fächer.
Die Nachfrage nach diesen Berufen steigt, gerade in den letzten Jahren,
wo jetzt die Cyberbedrohung, wie es so schön heißt, auch in zunehmendem Maße wahrgenommen wird von Unternehmen,
nur die finden halt überhaupt keine gut ausgebildeten Leute,
weil es offensichtlich eher ein zurückgehendes Interesse gibt, da auch wirklich reinzugehen.
Da fragt man sich ja, seit wann sind denn Berufsbilder uninteressant, die sehr gefragt und gut bezahlt sind,
warum gehen da die Leute nicht rein.
Hast du da eine Vorstellung, was da gerade schiefläuft oder vielleicht schon seit längerem schiefläuft?
Es sind sicherlich viele Faktoren, die da zusammenkommen.
Also was wir hier insbesondere bei der jetzigen Generation sehen, ist,
oder was heißt jetzige Generation…
Also ob man jetzt Richtung Gen Z geht oder auch die Alphas,
die jetzt ja langsam auch im Bereich Schule und bald fertig unterwegs sind,
ist es insbesondere auch durch eine sehr sehr hohe Vernetzung im Sinne auch der SocialMedia-Nutzung,
dass wir eine Generation jetzt gerade ranziehen, die große Herausforderung hat, Schein und Sein zu unterscheiden.
Und wenn man eben einfach sieht, auch diese instagramability oder sonst was,
wie früh das einsetzt und was für fatale Folgen das hat.
Und auch was für mitunter unrichtige Stereotypen einfach dadurch weiter mit unterstützt werden.
Das ist etwas, was, glaube ich, die jungen Menschen massiv verunsichert
und was wir dadurch einfach auch neu angehen müssen.
Eine riesige Wahlfreiheit, ich kann eigentlich alles machen, ist nichts, was dabei hilft,
eine fundierte und klare Entscheidung zu treffen.
Und das eben dadurch zu umgehen, dass man einfach zeigt, wieviel Spaß das machen kann
und dass man nicht der Hardcoreprogrammierer sein muss, um da irgendwo einen Fuß auf den Boden zu kriegen
und dass insbesondere im Bereich der Informatik im weiteren Sinne ganz viele praktische,
soziale verbindende organisatorische Fähigkeiten gefragt sind,
dadurch können wir, glaube ich, dieser nach meiner Einschätzung falschen Überstilisierung von diesen Berufen entgegenwirken.
Ja gut, das ist so der Ausblick auf die Zukunft, aber die Frage ist,
was hat denn Deutschland bisher so falsch gemacht?
Also ich meine, was läuft denn da schief, dass das Interesse gar nicht da ist und sogar noch zurückgeht,
obwohl im Prinzip der Markt danach schreit und das tut er jetzt auch nicht erst seit zwei Jahren,
sondern das ist ja, keine Ahnung, schon seit 20-30 Jahren schon fast so eine Binsenweisheit,
dass, wenn man was mit Computern macht, dass das Zukunft hat so.
War sogar bei mir in der Schule schon so.
Naja eben, trotz alledem scheint es auch irgendetwas zu geben und ich habe auch immer so ein bisschen diese Vermutung,
das ist auch so ein generelles Ding, wenn man jetzt mal einfach schaut, wie Deutschland an sich Digitalisierung fortwährend verschläft
und sich dabei verhaspelt, keine Projekte richtig auf die Kette kriegt, immer noch eine digitale Mangelinfrastruktur haben,
obwohl das Thema auch schon seit 20 Jahren da ist.
Also es ist ja sozusagen eine generelle Unfähigkeit, die hier um sich zu greifen scheint.
Hast du irgendwie eine Idee, woran es liegen kann, dass wir da so aufgestellt sind oder vielmehr nicht aufgestellt sind?
Wenn du dir den Gründungsbereich zum Beispiel anguckst, ist etwas, was uns unglaublich Herausforderungen macht,
ist diese krasse Überbürokratisierung eines jeden Schrittes in Deutschland.
Und das ist im Bereich der Schulen ganz genau so.
Also ich weiß nicht, wer den Bildungsföderalismus erfunden hat,
aber es ist etwas, wo man sagt, wenn wir schnell gute Sachen umsetzen,
glaube ich, dass es fatal ist erst mal zu sagen, ja wir müssen 16 mal jetzt das gleich entwickeln,
damit man hinterher sieht, wer es am besten gemacht hat.
Das Schulsystem, was wir immer noch haben, kommt aus einer Zeit, wo es darum ging,
in Preußen die Kinder von den Feldern zu holen.
Ich weiß nicht wie es dir geht, in meinem Freundeskreis arbeiten nicht mehr sehr viele Kinder auf Feldern hier in Deutschland.
Und das ist etwas, wir bilden aktuell für eine Zukunft aus, die es nach meiner Einschätzung so nicht mehr gibt.
Alleine wenn du dir die Abschlussprüfung anguckst, ist da irgendwas mit Kollaboration, mit Zusammenarbeit,
mit gemeinschaftlich Sachen entwickeln?
Wird sofort als Betrug geahndet.
Man muss reproduzieren, es ist ganz cool, wenn man es auf neue Fragestellungen anwenden kann,
aber das, worauf es ankommt, was wir auch später in der Berufswelt brauchen,
das ist eben halt da noch ziemliches Neuland.
Natürlich kann man noch argumentieren, dass eine Schule nicht optimiert auf die Berufswelt ausbilden sollte.
Ja, okay.
Es geht auch darum, grundlegende Werte zu vermitteln und auch ein Grundlagenwissen drauf zu schaffen.
Aber in der heutigen Zeit sehen wir verstärkt, dass du auch bei den Kindern viel mehr diesen Reason Why brauchst.
Warum soll ich das eigentlich lernen?
Wenn ich mit meinem Sohn und ich liebe es, mit ihm Mathe zu machen, wirklich sagen kann,
wofür brauchst du denn das von der Berechnung her?
Wie kannst denn du rausfinden, was wie zusammenhängt, wenn du eben halt,
Evergreen ist ein Dreisatz, damit kannst du ja fast alles berechnen, einen großen Teil.
Wenn der weiß warum er das macht, der läuft von selbst.
Einfach dieses, ist so weil ist so und steht im Lehrplan und du musst das auswendig lernen,
damit werden wir die Kinder heute nicht mehr erreichen.
Und da wirklich praktischer reinzugehen und Sachen praktisch und pragmatisch zu lösen,
das ist halt aufgrund der unglaublich hohen Bürokratie hier in Deutschland wahnsinnig schwierig.
Und ja, da ist die Schule eigentlich gar nicht so viel schlechter als die Bundesrepublik im Durchschnitt,
da haben wir wahnsinnig viel Raum for Improvement.
Und realisiert das irgendjemand außer dir?
Also hast du das Gefühl, im Kontakt mit den Schulen, dass sich da was tut von unten nach oben
oder vielleicht sogar von oben nach unten, weil langsam wird es ja Zeit.
Wir haben in Deutschland kein Verständnisproblem, sondern das Umsetzungsproblem, das kennst du ja auch.
Also sagen wir mal so, Schulbashing liegt mir fern, weil ich sehe,
was für unglaublich große Herausforderungen die Schulen meistern.
Sie übernehmen ja auch in einigen Bereichen grundlegende Erziehungsaufgaben.
Wenn wir sehen, mein Vater sagte damals, die Konzentrationsfähigkeit eines Kindes wird auf dem Wickeltisch angelegt
und im Kinderwagen, durch das Halten des Augenkontaktes zu Mutter oder Vater,
wer auch immer da gerade beschäftigt ist.
Wo haben junge Eltern ihre Augen, wenn Sie mit dem Kind unterwegs sind?
Auf dem Handy.
Und das wirklich einfach mitzudenken, was Schulen da leisten.
Ich kenne unglaublich wirklich begeisterte Lehrkräfte, Schulleitungen,
die versuchen, alles zu ändern und die halt eben auch so ein bisschen in ihrem Rahmen gefangen sind.
Ich sehe aber auch, dass solche Sachen wie die Hacker School und wir gehen online in Schulen
und mit Zoom, das ist, man kann alles diskutieren, aber ich sehe,
dass die Bereitschaft steigt, auch wirklich Sachen zu machen.
Aber nur wegen Corona oder?
Du kennst ja die Grafik mit, wer hat die Digitalisierung Ihrer Firma vorangetrieben, CEO, CIO oder Covid?
Natürlich, Menschen sind unglaublich bequem und was sagte, ich glaube,
der Gerald Hütter sagte das, warum ändert sich das Schulsystem nicht?
Ist der zweite Satz der Thermodynamik, jedes System verharrt auf dem Zustand,
wo es am wenigstmöglich Energie verbraucht und das ist sicherlich keine Veränderung.
Und da wirklich konstant diesen Veränderungswunsch und -druck reinzubringen und hochzuhalten.
Ein System Schule kannst du nicht von außen verändern oder nur begrenzt.
Du musst es von innen verändern.
Und da sehe ich erste Impulse, aber ja, ich glaube, dass wir auf die Hacker School kurzfristig
oder Initiativen wie die Hacker School kurzfristig nicht verzichten können,
weil wir eben genau solche Brandbeschleuniger sind und sagen,
komm wir gehen da rein, wir machen das, wir versuchen, wir bieten euch was an,
was euch nicht wehtut und ich glaube, davon braucht es einfach viel mehr,
damit einfach noch mehr Menschen mitmachen.
Vielleicht noch mal so ein bisschen auf der Metaebene zu bleiben,
auch wenn wir da schon im Prinzip drüber gesprochen haben.
Aber du hast vorhin auch so von algorithmischem Denken, kritischem Denken gesprochen.
Inwiefern, denkst du, ist das ein Ergebnis dieser, vielleicht jetzt nicht unbedingt eurer Kurse,
sondern inwiefern …
Also wie verstehst du das?
Vielleicht kannst du das mal kurz erklären, was du meinst mit algorithmischem Denken und kritischem Denken.
Und wie kann das entstehen?
Ich sehe, dass junge Menschen heutzutage den Eindruck haben,
dass so was wie Alexa oder jedwede Art der Spracherkennung einen intelligenten Computer auf der anderen Seite hat.
Und das spannende ist, wenn wir in Schulklassen reingehen und sagen,
wer von euch denkt, dass ein Computer intelligent ist?
Dann gehen erst mal die ganzen Hände hoch.
Und klar zu machen, dass ein Computer, strunzdumm ist jetzt auch wieder nicht das richtige,
aber dass ein Computer nicht macht was man meint, sondern was man ihm sagt.
Und dass es eigene Sprachen gibt, wie Anweisungen in auch Maschinen verständlich formuliert werden müssen.
Das ist ein total spannendes Erlebnis für Kids.
Und was wir häufig machen ist programmieren ohne Computer.
Wir lassen sie in Paaren zusammenarbeiten, einer ist der Programmierer,
der andere ist der Roboter und der Programmierer muss den Roboter dazu bringen,
ein Schokobon auszupacken und ihn zu essen.
Und da zu sehen, wie verdammt schwierig das ist, ganz konkrete detaillierte Anweisungen zu geben.
Und auch dadurch zu erfahren, was man, auch wenn man weiterdenkt Richtung künstliche Intelligenz
im Bereich der Gesichtserkennung, was muss man alles beachten
und was sind die Biases, die sich da verstecken?
Also man sieht ja auch, dass zum Beispiel Gesichter von farbigen Menschen viel schlechter erkannt werden als die von weißen.
Der Bias der KI mit, es sind weiße Männer zwischen 20 und 40,
vollkommen klar, dass da nicht alles bedacht wird.
Und das eben genau an diesen Stellen mit den Kindern zu problematisieren,
ist etwas, wo sie hinterher ganz anders auf die Welt blicken
und in ersten Schritten beginnen zu verstehen, warum ganz genaue Anweisungen
oder so was wie Maschinensprache extrem spannend ist, wenn sie Sachen auch automatisieren wollen.
Bzw. warum auch diese künstliche Intelligenz meistens gar nicht so intelligent ist, wie man das vielleicht glauben mag.
Nein, und dass Terminator 3 auch noch mal eine andere Kategorie ist, genau.
Wir hatte es schon so am Rande ein wenig angesprochen, aber ich wollte noch mal drauf eingehen
und das ist natürlich jetzt konkret auch die Situation von MINT-Berufswünschen
und diesen ganzen Programmierkursen und den Mädchen und jungen Frauen,
für die ihr ja auch spezielle Angebote habt.
Hast du schon gesagt, Girls School wendet sich auch an alle Altersgruppen,
sozusagen als außerschulische Kurse dann natürlich.
Inwiefern ist das anders aufgestellt, inwiefern seht ihr da den Bedarf dafür?
Welche Rolle spielt das bei euch?
Man begeistert Mädels halt einfach anders.
Also ich hatte ja erwähnt, ich habe ja seit 20 Jahren einen ITler zu Hause.
Und das wundervolle ist, abgesehen davon, dass er nicht erwachsen wird, ist,
ich kann aus erster Hand belegen, es reicht, wenn etwas neu ist und blinkt
um sich das begeistert anzugucken.
Hat eine neue Funktion, muss ich ausprobieren, hier guck mal.
Jetzt ist halt der Temperaturfühler bei den Hühnern, der blinkt jetzt sogar.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch, das ist super und das macht auch ganz viel Spaß.
Aber ganz ehrlich, so als Frau gesprochen interessiert mich das nicht, ob das Ding blinkt,
ich möchte wissen, ob ich damit mehr erreichen kann oder ob das, ich weiß nicht,
die Hühner vielleicht auch noch glücklicher macht oder so was und dann legen sie mehr Eier.
Also es ist halt etwas, wir sehen insbesondere bei Mädels, die, im Fachwort gesagt,
Kontextualisierung, warum mache ich etwas, ist so viel wichtiger.
Und wenn wir Kurse zum Beispiel mit der Sensebox geben, das ist so eine vorbereitete Box,
die mit ganz vielen Sensoren, wo du Sachen messen kannst wie Feinstaub oder was weiß ich was,
wenn du wirklich sagst, okay damit machen wir was und noch irgendwas zu einem Umweltthema
und dann macht das auch noch eine weibliche Inspirese, dann sind alle Mädchen da.
Und genau das zu sehen, wir brauchen Rolemodels, wir brauchen tatsächlich mehr als nur,
es ist neu und blinkt, wir brauchen einen Grund, das zu tun und häufig auch was,
wo man sagen kann, kann ich damit irgendwas verbessern im ökologischen, im sozialen Sinne,
in was weiß ich welchem Sinne auch immer.
Damit kommen wir ganz anders an Mädels ran.
Und auch der Punkt, zu sagen, ich möchte mich auch für einen Beruf entscheiden,
wo ich Beruf und Familie gut miteinander vereinbaren kann, das ist etwas,
wenn man das ebenfalls mit fallen lässt, je nachdem wie alt die Mädels sind,
ist das was, was durchaus gehört wird.
Weil im IT-Bereich, ich kann arbeiten von wo aus ich will, wann ich will in weiten Teilen,
okay losgelöst von Teamstrukturen.
Also nicht in allen IT-Bereichen, aber mehr als in anderen.
Einfacher, als wenn ich irgendwo in einem Supermarkt an der Kasse sitze,
da habe ich selten die Möglichkeit mit, ach mir passt es gerade morgens zwischen 2 und 4, da wird der Laden nicht aufmachen.
Und das ist halt eine Flexibilität, die man auch noch mal so als Funfact oder Nutzenaspekt mit einfließen lassen kann.
Informatikstudium Anteil Frauen knapp 20 Prozent, glaube ich.
Ja. Aber so ein Studium macht ja auch noch nicht zwangsläufig jemanden,
der dann langfristig drin arbeitet.
Ja nein, ist richtig, aber ich meine, bei 20 Prozent würde ich mal sagen, das ist schon unterrepräsentiert.
Klar.
Also selbst wenn man noch andere Faktoren mit ausrechnet und andere Wege noch mit einschließt,
zeigt es ja schon, dass es irgendwie keinen Reiz hat und ich frage mich, was die Gründe dafür sind.
Ein Freund von mir sagte mal, er erzählt immer eine lustige Geschichte vom MIT,
wo sie einen Kurs mit Einführung in die Programmierung umbenannt haben,
the beauty und joy of Computing.
Mit dem Ergebnis, dass plötzlich die Frauenquote locker über 50 Prozent lag,
ich glaube, bei 70 oder 80.
Das spricht jetzt natürlich nicht für mein eigenes Geschlecht, an der Stelle zu sagen,
oh das klingt anders, das mach ich jetzt mal.
Aber es ist etwas, wo man sagt…
Es triggert einfach was anderes so, was man vielleicht erst mal so gar nicht gesehen hat,
dass das getriggert gehört.
Es ist auch so, wenn du dir anguckst, wieviele Jobbeschreibungen wirklich männlich formuliert sind,
mit diesen ganzen Attributen, die wir mit durchsetzungsstark, erfolgreich, wie auch immer,
es gibt ganz viele Sachen, die ganz klar männlich attribuiert sind.
Und dass wir da, wenn du das als Frau liest und denkst so, boah möchte ich das wirklich?
Dann kommt noch der Faktor dazu, ich hatte gehört, bei einem Mann reicht das,
wenn ungefähr, keine Ahnung, knapp die Hälfte passt, bei einer Frau muss gefühlt über 90 Prozent passen,
bevor sie sich auf eine Stelle bewirbt.
Und das ist halt was, wo wir uns langfristig einfach mal auch angucken müssen,
kriegen wir das hin, an der Stelle Gleichberechtigung nicht nur zu meinen,
sondern es eben auch wirklich umzusetzen.
Wenn wir bei unseren Mädels, bei den kleinen Mädchen nicht sagen, sie sind bossy,
sondern they are showing natural leadership tendencies.
Ich glaube, das ist von Sheryl Sandberg ein Zitat,
dass man wirklich einfach mal gucken muss, wie attribuieren wir wirklich auch Worte,
die wir verwenden und ja, wenn es hilft, ich bin für eine Quote auch in Vorständen,
ich bin auch für eine Paraphrasierung von Kursen, wenn es dazu beiträgt,
dass es eben halt wirklich die Begeisterung dafür triggert, sich damit auseinanderzusetzen,
dann müssen wir diesen Weg solange gehen wie es wichtig ist.
Was ist denn jetzt sozusagen die Zukunft, die du dir für die Hacker School vorstellst,
außer schneller, höher, weiter?
Inwiefern wollt ihr das weiter entwickeln?
Also vielleicht kannst du noch mal eine Zahl fallen lassen, so wieviele Kinder ihr im Jahr erreicht,
um mal dafür ein Gefühl zu bekommen und wie denkt ihr, was hat das noch für ein Potential für euch?
Also die Wunschzukunft für die Hacker School ist oder wäre, dass es uns nicht mehr braucht.
Die sehe ich aber nicht relativ bald.
Das Ziel, was ich vorhin sagte, ist, jedes Kind soll einmal programmiert haben,
bevor es sich für einen Beruf entscheidet.
Das kurzfristige Ziel oder mittelfristig, je nachdem wie du das einordnest, ist,
2025 wollen wir 100.000 Kinder pro Jahr erreichen.
Das heißt, wir brauchen ungefähr 17.000 ITlerInnen, die mit uns in Schulklassen,
das wird der größte Zahlenlieferant sozusagen werden, Dreiviertel der Kurse vermute ich,
oder Dreiviertel der Kinder, dass wir die über die Schulkurse erreichen.
Wir wollen jedes Jahr verdoppeln.
Dieses Jahr ist das Ziel bei 12.500 Kindern rauszulaufen.
Wir sind jetzt Ende August bei 8.000 Kindern, liegt super.
Also dicker Daumen, das werden wir von den Zahlen her, wenn da nicht irgendwas signifikant schiefläuft, erreichen können.
Wieviele nehmen an so einem Kurs im Schnitt dann teil?
Also Schulklassen wahrscheinlich eher so 30?
25-30, das ist unterschiedlich und entsprechend mit durch sechs haben wir die Inspirer.
Die Idee ist halt eben, die Strategie so zu bauen, dass wir zum einen näher mit Universitäten kooperieren
und das auch als Seminare anbieten, dass eben halt die StudentInnen bei uns als Inspirer auch Creditpoints sammeln können,
weil sie ja auch wirklich, sie sammeln ja Fähigkeiten, indem sie das vermitteln.
Wir arbeiten an Kooperationen mit Berufsschulen aus dem IT-Umfeld.
Wo man eben einfach sieht zum Beispiel, die e-Tech auf den Elbinseln hier in Hamburg, die haben 66 Klassen.
Über drei Jahre verteilt.
Das ist also jetzt alles auch gerade erst in Gesprächen, aber zu sehen,
wir haben erste Tests gemacht, dass es für die Azubine, die dort auch in der Schule sind,
ein totaler Mehrwert ist, dass sie sich da mit engagieren können,
dass wir gemeinschaftlich richtig viel lernen.
Und wenn die weitergeben können, was sie selber in der Schule gelernt haben,
in der Berufsschule, ist das top.
Und der dritte Ansatz, wo wir eben wirklich auch uns Richtung der großen Zahlen auf der Inspirer-Seite bewegen,
ist, dass wir einfach auch die Zusammenarbeit mit den Unternehmen verändern.
Also von, hast du zwei ITler, ich brauche dringend noch welche, zu,
wieviele Azubis hast du, 150, super, ich nehme alle und das zweimal.
Das wir da die Nutzenargumentation den Firmen gegenüber ganz klar aufzeigen können,
dass wir das nicht nur machen, weil wir als non profit einfach mal sonst nichts anderes zu tun haben,
sondern dass es wirklich darum geht, grundsätzlich junge Menschen dafür zu begeistern
und sich für Zukunftsberufe zu entscheiden und den Azubis und den Azubinen,
die eben halt da schon unterwegs sind, die Möglichkeit zu geben,
durch die Vermittlung des eigenen Wissens selber das zu lernen.
Man sagt ja immer, wenn du es deiner Großmutter erklären kannst, hast du es selber verstanden.
Wir haben keine Großmütter, aber wir haben Kinder und das im großen Umfang.
Und ich glaube, dass so, wenn die Firmen ihre Verantwortung wahrnehmen,
sich mit auch für digitale Bildung zu engagieren und die Schulen das zulassen und sich öffnen,
mit uns als non profit als gemeinnützigem Träger dazwischen, dass wir die Zahlen mit den 100.000 Kindern pro Jahr auf jeden Fall erreichen werden.
Bei 12.500 als Ziel, dann ich habe es mal so grob überschlagen, habt ihr so 2-3 Kurse pro Wochentag vor der Nase,
wenn ich das richtig sehe, so über das Jahr verteilt?
Ja, du kannst es nicht ganz über den Mittelwert nehmen vor dem Hintergrund,
es gibt ja auch tatsächlich im Sommer immer mal diese Ferien oder es gibt immer wieder Ferien,
wo man sieht, über den Sommer ist es eher so ein bisschen ruhiger.
Es gibt auch Sonderevents, wo wir eben zum Beispiel auf der Ideen-Expo in Hannover,
da haben wir ganz viele Kurse mit angeboten.
Da waren ja, ich weiß gar nicht wieviele Kids dieses Jahr da waren,
aber das letzte Mal waren es über 400.000 und da hatten wir auch bei uns viele Kinder,
mit denen wir da arbeiten konnten, also auch wirklich da Kurse vor Ort zu geben
in separaten Räumlichkeiten oder ähnliches.
Es gibt immer Peaks, wo du auch wirklich siehst, da haben Unternehmen Zeit und Lust, was zu machen.
Es gibt auch Phasen, wo man sieht, wie eben halt den Sommer, da ist das egal,
entweder bist du im Urlaub oder du machst Urlaubsvertretung für andere mit.
Aber letztendlich jetzt zu sagen, dass man so ganz grob versucht, linear dranzubleiben,
das zweite Halbjahr ist immer stärker als das erste, weil wir da auf den bereits gemachten Kontakten aufsetzen können.
Auf der anderen Seite ist das erst Halbjahr länger als das zweite, weil die Sommerferien halt Anfang des zweiten liegen.
Aber ja, das ist die Größenordnung, also jetzt nach den Sommerferien wird es so sein,
dass wir täglich höchstwahrscheinlich immer zwei Kurse haben.
Und diese Unternehmen spielen ja bei euch eine relativ große Rolle,
die bieten die Orte an, das heißt, das ist ja im Prinzip so eine Art,
das ist auch so ein sozialer Payback, könnte man jetzt sozusagen sagen,
so eine Dividende, die quasi die Unternehmen dann wieder in die Bildung stecken.
Was ja oft auch gefordert wird, tun sie sicherlich auf andere Ebene auch.
Nur hier das eben konkret zu machen, hat ja so eine Art Doppelnutzen.
Also sowohl man verbessert was im Idealfall, aber man verbessert ja auch,
also man gibt ja auch seinen eigenen Mitarbeitern und insbesondere den Auszubildenden auch eine spezielle Herausforderung,
die sich ja dann letzten Endes auch im Unternehmen wiederum positiv auszahlen kann.
Also ich glaube, wenn man einmal so einen Lernprozess, also einen Lehrprozess,
einen Lehrprozess durchgemacht hat und in so einer Situation bestehen kann,
kann das ja auch so die eigenen Communicationskills ein wenig verbessern
oder vielleicht sogar signifikant verbessern, würde ich fast sagen.
Kriegt ihr da entsprechendes Feedback von den Unternehmen?
Ist das irgendwie etwas, worüber gesprochen wird?
Müsst ihr da Überzeugungsarbeit leisten oder ist das irgendwie etwas, was schon verstanden wird?
Also wir kriegen von den Unternehmen, mit denen wir schon arbeiten, großartiges Feedback.
Also wir sehen halt jetzt auch, wir sind mit einem sehr großen IT-Systemhaus gerade dabei zu gucken,
wie kriegen wir das hin, dass wir halt wirklich das allen Azubis ermöglichen,
natürlich ohne Druck zu machen, weil einige sind sehr jung, wenn sie da reinkommen.
Und es soll niemand, wer wirklich nicht möchte, das hilft nichts,
Menschen dazu zu zwingen, bringt nichts, aber sie zu ermuntern und ganz klar zu sagen,
hey wir würden das super begrüßen, wenn ihr mitmacht, ihr könnt so viel für euch lernen,
alleine dabei, als das den neuen Azubis vorgestellt worden ist, das haben zwei oder drei Azubis gemacht,
die schon mehrfach Kurse gegeben haben, was für ein besseres Kompliment kannst du kriegen?
Und wirklich jetzt mit dieser Überzeugung rauszugehen, wir wissen, es ist richtig,
wir wissen, es funktioniert und wir können euch, liebe Unternehmen, so viel Gehassel abnehmen,
einfach das selber zu organisieren, das ist ein riesiger Aufwand.
Aber wir haben die Prozesse stehen, ey come on, wir machen das seit 2014.
Und da wirklich zu haben, wir haben so viel gelernt und all das, was nicht das Programmieren ist,
also all das, wo wir euch nicht wirklich notwendigerweise brauchen, das nehmen wir euch ab,
da kümmern wir uns drum, wir haben das hier vorbereitet.
Wir haben ja, wir haben bis jetzt schon, wir müssten jetzt knapp über 20.000 Kinder bei uns in der Hacker School gehabt haben,
da lernt man schon was.
Und diese Erfahrung einfließen zu lassen, auch das Feedback einfließen zu lassen.
Wir haben jetzt zum Beispiel gerade einen neuen Python-Code gebaut, weil wir gesehen haben,
es hilft, wenn wir beim Programmieren mehr Visualisierung haben, weil die Kinder da besser das greifen können.
Und solche Sachen, das können wir über das Stück der großen Zahl sehr gut bei uns einbauen
und auch weil wir dadurch, dass wir gemeinnützig sind, dafür Fördergelder beschaffen können.
Und die Unternehmen da einzusetzen, wo wir sie wirklich brauchen, das kommt bei den Unternehmen gut an,
das wird zunehmend mehr verstanden.
Ja, manchmal dauert das seine Prozesse, insbesondere wenn man eben im öffentlichen Bereich mit Unternehmen arbeitet,
die haben Vorlauffristen von locker einem Jahr und bis man das dann wirklich einplanen kann.
Aber die Bereitschaft, Sachen zu pilotieren, auszuprobieren und wirklich dann auch oft mit der Unterstützung auch der Geschäftsführungsebene zu sagen,
komm wir machen das jetzt, wir haben doch gar keine andere Wahl,
lasst uns die Power, die wir haben, dafür nutzen, dass wir junge Menschen für Zukunftsberufe begeistern,
wir haben eh wenig genug davon hier.
Und dieses leave no one behind, das ist ja heute wichtiger denn je zuvor,
weil es immer wieder auch Fälle gibt, ich weiß nicht, ob du die Firma Lemontaps kennst,
Raji, der erzählte mir mal, der war so schlecht in Deutsch, dass die Deutschlehrerin seinem Vater gesagt hat,
hier schalt das Internet ab, der muss mehr Deutsch lesen.
Und da hatte nur eine Stunde Internetzeit am Tag und die Stunde, das hat ihn so geärgert,
hat er genutzt, um rauszufinden, wie er diese Sperre umgehen kann und das hat er geschafft.
Aber als er das dann konnte, hat er gemerkt, wie geil das ist, Sachen zu verändern
und wirklich steuern zu können und hat dann so viele sinnvolle Sachen online gemacht
und hat jetzt, glaube ich, die dritte Firma gegründet, das ist ein genialer Mann.
Und so, der ist auch bei dieser Organisation two hearts, wo du diese beiden Staatsbürgerschaften hast,
auch da als Rolemodel mit aktiv.
Und wenn wir das hinkriegen, junge Menschen so anzusprechen, dass sie Bock darauf haben, was zu verändern
und an sich selber zu glauben, dann ist leave noone behind auf einmal gar nicht mehr so das ganz große Problem.
Und dafür brauchen wir die Unternehmen und dafür brauchen wir alternative Ansprachewege.
Hacken macht glücklich.
/lacht/ Auf jeden Fall macht es Spaß.
Du hast gerade erwähnt, ihr arbeitet an einem Kursmaterial.
Das ist vielleicht auch so ein Punkt, den wir gar nicht angesprochen haben bisher.
Wenn diese Kurse gegeben werden, dann stehen sozusagen diese Leute auch nicht mit nichts da
und müssen sich selber sozusagen Kurse ausdenken, sondern das ist sozusagen schon ein halbwegs gemachtes Nest,
in das man sich dann begibt.
Das heißt, die Leute melden sich freiwillig, sie führen diese Kurse durch, helfen den Kids
und sind sozusagen AnsprechpartnerInnen in dem Moment, aber es gibt schon vorbereitetes Material,
mit dem gearbeitet werden kann, was ihr entwickelt?
Ja. Also insbesondere im Schulbereich, da hast du ja drei Stunden Programmierzeit.
Innerhalb von drei Stunden solltest du schon so eine Idee haben, wo du hinkommen willst.
An den Wochenenden ist das etwas einfacher, weil innerhalb von acht Stunden kannst du ja ganz andere Schwerpunktsetzungen
und noch Workarounds und alles weitere machen.
Wir ermuntern trotzdem die Inspirer, mit denen wir arbeiten, jederzeit off script zu gehen,
wenn die Kinder sie rufen.
Weil man muss, und das ist halt das, was die auch lernen, wirklich zu gucken,
was sagt mein Gegenüber eigentlich, wo will der hin, wohin führt der mich?
Und da zu sehen, wenn die Kinder in eine andere Richtung driften,
wo man sagt, ja dann geht doch off script, das ist jetzt nichts, wo ihr müsst das Skript unbedingt durchziehen
und der Kurs war nur erfolgreich, wenn ihr auch den letzten Punkt gesetzt habt.
Sondern seht zu, dass die Kinderaugen leuchten, dass sie selber merken,
sie können etwas verändern, sie können etwas schaffen, sie kriegen das hin.
Und das ist unsere Empfehlung, damit funktioniert das Bombe, aber wenn ihr zwischenzeitlich merkt,
ihr müsst da was anpassen, macht das, völlig in Ordnung.
Außerschulisch haben wir halt auch diverse Konzepte, wo Inspirer auch draufgucken können und sagen,
ah super, ich möchte lieber was mit C machen oder mit, völlig egal, setze die Programmiersprache deiner Wahl ein,
aber ich gucke mir mal das Pythonkonzept an, dann weiß ich ungefähr, auf welchem Niveau das ist,
super, ich mache das oder ich baue mir was eigenes, aber dann habe ich da Referenzen.
Und da bauen wir auch geraden noch mal so einen, ich sage mal, Rahmen mit,
wie erstelle ich eigene Kurse.
Im Moment betreuen wir das auch noch mit etwas größerem Aufwand immer durch einen Kollegen,
der auch da Unternehmen zur Verfügung steht oder Inspirern.
Aber dass auch da noch mal ein bisschen mehr skalierungsfähig zu kriegen,
dass es einfacher ist einzuschätzen, wie kann ich eigentlich meine Kurse bauen,
wenn ich das möchte oder welchen nehme ich, da arbeiten wir auch noch dran, das auszuweiten.
Ist ja auch ein Trend.
Also es gibt ja eine ganze Menge online Lernplattformen fürs Programmieren mittlerweile,
vor allem natürlich aus den USA heraus, wo das auch eine ganz andere Kultur hat, glaube ich.
Also wo Computer und dieses ganze Programmieren, wo das nicht mit so vielen Ängsten,
sondern eher mit Chancen so primär immer bedacht ist.
Ist auch glaube ich ein bisschen diese amerikanische Art, so fail ist da nicht so schlimm.
Und hier sind so Niederlagen, die haben immer so einen negative Bedeutung und davor haben dann alle Angst, zu scheitern.
Davon unabhängig, schaut ihr euch das an, was sich da jetzt gerade so entwickelt?
Weil das scheint eine relativ rasante Entwicklung zu nehmen, mit so online Lernplattformen,
auch speziell für so MINT-Bereiche, /unverständlich/ ähnlich Sachen, die ja genau eigentlich auf diesen Bereich abzielen.
Die also sagen, ihr wollt Programmieren lernen, ihr wollt Technik lernen,
ihr wollt mathematische Zusammenhänge verstehen, hier haben wir irgendwie eine online Lernplattform.
Ist mega.
Also das wirklich zu sehen, was sich da alles entwickelt, das ist toll.
Also es gibt auch, auch wenn du dir Udacity oder sonst was anguckst, unglaublich gute Ansätze.
Und sagen wir so, die Herausforderung ist, bevor du dich das traust oder das machst,
musst du erstens wissen, dass du dich das trauen kannst und du musst wissen, wonach du guckst.
Und das ist eben etwas, wo wir auch in unserer Verweisberatung,
bei diesem Wege in die IT, geh hierhin, geh dahin, egal was du tust, aber geh irgendwo hin,
wo wir auch auf die, die wir kennen, immer verweisen.
Aber genau dadurch hoffen, durch das was wir tun, diesen Einstieg hinzukriegen
und die Berufe, die in diesem weiteren Skillset sind, überhaupt in das Relevantset,
in diese Auswahlmöglichkeiten bei jungen Menschen zu kriegen.
Das ist etwas, was keine dieser Plattformen leisten kann.
Weil die Entscheidung, da drauf zu gehen, die muss ja erstmal fallen.
Und dafür brauche ich diese Berufsoptionen überhaupt in dem Set,
so weit top of mind, dass ich da wirklich was drauf aussuchen kann.
Und wenn ich überhaupt nicht denke, ich könnte ja was mit vielleicht IT oder Informatik
oder überhaupt Digitalisierung machen, dann werde ich dagegen immun sein.
Und das so als Vorstufe mit reinzuschalten, unsere Arbeit macht es leichter,
weil wir dann schneller abgeben können, im Sinne von Verweisberatung und Empfehlen.
Ich finde es prima.
Ja, haben wir noch irgendwas wichtiges ungesagt gelassen, was dir noch auf dem Herzen liegt über euer Projekt?
Ansonsten, glaube ich, haben wir alles abgeklappert.
Wir haben über viele Sachen gesprochen.
Was ich halt sehe, was auch zunimmt, ist eben etwas, auch das worüber wir uns im weiteren Sinne hier kennengelernt haben,
dass es einfach zunehmend Initiativen auch von Stiftungen oder vom Stifterverband gibt,
wo eben halt auch teilweise mit Unternehmen, aber auch solche Förderprogramme und Wettbewerbe aufgelegt werden,
die insbesondere jetzt in unserem Fall, weil wir auch das unglaubliche Privileg hatten,
im letzten Jahr dieses digital engagiert gewinnen zu können,
die einen unglaublichen Speed reinbringen, weil dadurch kriegen Initiativen wie wir Kontakt zu richtigen Fachleuten,
die wir uns niemals leisten könnten, wenn man das mit Sozialgehältern bezahlen möchte,
ist das eher symbolisch.
Aber dadurch wirklich die Wichtigkeit dieser ganzen Thematik hochzuheben
und ihr auch eine Sichtbarkeit zu geben, das ist etwas, was ich im Trend auch sehe
und was mich halt wirklich begeistert.
Schön Julia, ich sage vielen Dank für die Ausführungen zur Hacker School.
Es war mir ein Vergnügen, hat viel Spaß gemacht.
Und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören hier bei Forschergeist.
Bald geht es wieder weiter, bis dahin sage ich, tschüss und bis bald.